you
in our series of more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us
despite the partisan divisions in
Washington we found one guy who's
working in Congress who has the support
of both the Democrats and the
Republicans that's partly because he
sure has had a lot of practice birdy
Bowman is his name he started working on
Capitol Hill during World War two
and he is still on the job as the Senate
senior staffer Nancy Cordes is on the
hill where she learned this 88 year old
guy has no plans to slow down Nancy good
morning can't wait to meet him he is a
great guy just to put his longevity into
perspective Gale the longest-serving
current senator has been here on Capitol
Hill for 44 years
birdy Bowman has been working here for
three quarters of a century and along
the way he has become a confidant to
Giants of the right and the left I may
have to start down at that Inn on the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee there
are junior senators there are senior
senators and then there's birdy Bowman
it isn't just about his age 88 and going
strong it's that he started running this
hearing room in 1966 every moment the
former clerk of this committee for 500
years at every key hearing he's the one
you see in the corner of the frame
escorting witnesses fixing the mics his
name is birdie born and keeping the
powerful in check
mr. Bowman he has outlasted all of it
mm-hmm rigorous timekeeper birdie came
to Capitol Hill when he was 13 years old
he ran away from his South Carolina home
after a chance meeting with his senator
Burnett maybank before he can get in
this car I was pulling on his coat tail
if I come to Washington can I stop by
see he said yes what did you think you
were gonna do when you got to Washington
I didn't know it was a future that I was
headed for somewhere but where I was
headed for
I don't know I was just bowled so he
hopped a train and headed straight to me
banks office on Capitol Hill he gave me
a job sweeping the cap on the steps at
that time and paid me out of his own
pocket $2.00 a week that was 1944 birdie
went on to do stints as a Capitol
janitor a cook and shining senators
shoes Linda Johnson used to love to get
dressy Bernie how's my books there you
got him looking good
can I see my face as a year yeah I know
you can see your face Ben and I can by
the time he got to the Foreign Relations
Committee birdie seemed to know more
about Congress than most of its members
he made senators look good yeah
former Senator Chuck Hagel is a
Republican Democrat Tim Kaine is still
on the committee
he reminds us of something very
important that we've lost civility every
new senator gets a crash course from
birdie oh I tell them you know you gotta
kind of when you walk out to go do
looking therefore right it's a hello hi
you this morning a lot of staffers would
be intimidated to tell the Senate or
something like that I can't be
intimidated where I was taught how to
treat people I treat him too good one of
those people was a young messenger who
sent us this video he was exactly the
kind of person you'd want to take you
under his wing if you're a 20 year old
student just working in your first job
in Washington we want you to have this
now Washington is returning the favor
we're just honored to name this new
building after you the bird eh Bowman
building putting birdies name atop the
new headquarters of the Senate Federal
Credit Union I didn't believe it at
first I was really shocked and all right
isn't that great that's amazing and I
feel so honored I've just come to have
his guide in the world at 88 birdy
Bowman has no plans to retire he says
his doctor has told him to slow down but
he told me that he knows he's still the
best at his job which is the kind of
confidence that is hard earned after
seventy-five years of experience don't
you Nancy I just love that story - what
a treasure Bertie Bowman is and
congratulations on having a building
game day yeah right there that he's not
slowing down you can tell he's needed
there that word civility yeah yeah B
keeps trying to teach it nice Nancy
salutes you